and silent the whole room silent and my
knees are shaking my knees are shaking
my heart was beard I didn't know what
was gonna happen
like a sofa but [ __ ] saw all right
she sees an giggy's geez boy
so same or same old youtubers like
comment sub that audio peeps your
support fires in your your Apple these
subscribe it get that automatic download
and as always [ __ ] Giggs patreon
links in the description it's on the
Instagram become a patreon get that
extra content get some merch from us
much it's gonna be droppin soon we've
got a cheeky tour business meeting
tomorrow with designer friend of mine so
we're going to be dropping so much for
you guys it's gonna be good man I'm
excited
the designs I've got in my head in my
head up off so yeah yeah patreon forward
slash shit's and gigs and yeah man was
it [ __ ] some geeks podcast well for
Pedro yeah for patreon now actually I
think it's just think it's pretty funny
you'll find it you will find it is all
over gasps oh yeah the links become a
patreon from three-pound get that extra
content get some discounts help you boys
out make it permanent yes with podcast
yeah she's in gigs so patreon
patreon.com forward slash sheets and
gigs podcast bang or if you want to
download the app go in the search bar
and just type in shits and get on load
that might make it easy for you so I'll
make it so much easier yourself you just
don't know what the [ __ ] you want to do
man oh yeah Ranma query hit what was do
you remember your first social media
mm-hmm what was it
MySpace just about same well I think
mine was mice visible I remember MySpace
broke my face here this is I was
thinking about MySpace a few weeks ago
my heavy my sweet was sick heavy had
your own playlist that you later thing
bro and top friends and that people use
top friends yeah this is the same top
fence was drama top friends drama
because I remember I got my first like
semi serious girlfriend yeah well I had
my space yeah I was like 16 15 16
space obviously you got it up friends
yeah so at the time I'm still a kid at
the time if your girlfriend ain't even
in the top three top arms awesome bros
beef
it's [ __ ] beef so I had to put her in
there yeah and I'm thinking Who am I
gonna - these are the homies who am I
gonna have to cut from the top friend
stressed for days I kind of remember who
I - but I had to get someone out do you
remember the time we're on snapchat
showed you your favorite friends as well
do you remember did you ever used to
snapchat like back in the day like when
it first first ride - dude I had it had
like your favorite like so I think if
for example you clicked my name and it
showed like who's the highest in my
friends who's the second I'll show you
interact I do I do remember that used to
be drama
oh when people your girl can see who are
you talking to if it's not me Jan I mean
big man am I'm texting your call you I
don't need to snapchat
bro [ __ ] laughs now think yeah man
people and relationships were hating
snapchat same with Instagram and they're
that great for the heaven-sent
heaven-sent like all she's ever like I
love a - I love a double time you love
its ways for that's what I feel like I'm
doing Instagram Oh adjust this or a
service I'm doing exactly what it says
on the tin yeah it's true it's true it's
true I'm B for that one oh it's a new
man I used to like [ __ ] because I want
to come back to it you know a lot post
you've like yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
hard to find now bro I tried to look for
it the other day it took me like 17
minutes ages do you know what they did
you know what tab but they should ab add
on people's instagrams so you've got the
three tabs to nominate you've got your
pictures and photos you've been tagged
in there should be a third one if you go
on let's say I'm going on your page for
example there should be a third tab that
shows pictures I've light of you does
that make sense
so if I'm going on your page and I go on
tab go into town that's all your
pictures go on tab 2 that's the photos
you've been tagged in 3
I have liked on your page so let's say
for example you said you were trying to
find a photo yeah you said it's instead
of going through all the furtive view
lights from every single page you've
liked if I go into your page you'll see
it I see like three pics you've liked to
have the hundred pics you post the a and
that's just like that would I don't know
why because there are times where I'm
thinking I've liked this picture but
can't what because it was I'm scrolling
I feel like that's it will benefit some
people so if you list Instagram if you
ever if you ever listen to this or
something that works in histogram and
you do that I would know you coined it
with me yeah Bravo
we won my peas because run me my bag run
me my bag but yeah boy what this is how
you know I was stupid from early this is
how you know the concert the the
concepts of how do I say it like
standing out yeah it's rough when you're
young yeah like you can't stand out yeah
you can't be someone who stands out
especially for like comedy yeah so when
I was on myspace right yeah I used to
get bored at home phone this is when I'm
on my summer breaks or whatever and I'm
bored at home and then I fought ah cuz I
don't think he could upload videos on
MySpace you could just pictures and
audio yeah yeah yeah so I wanted to do
this whole thing I had this thing idea
in my head right
this whole comedy if I was bored and
this is when I was boxing yeah and I was
bored at home no one else at home is
just me and my [ __ ] dog and I thought
I'm gonna come up with this entire
picture collage where people can run
through and it's gonna be around by
around fight boxing match between me and
my little dog and in my head it was
funny fat in my head is just gonna be
bare freeze frames from yeah from the
fight fight yeah I'm [ __ ] sweating
yeah hahahaha gumshoes half hour I'm the
whole time my dogs just straight face is
calm I know everybody more egg drop in
my head that's funny because I've seen
your dog I don't look like that's funny
to me bro so I was I planned out for
years and I was like bro said I've got
my gloves on gum shield yeah man's doing
everything got pepper
just everything like gas like this is
going this is going this is going and
then when push came to shove I had all
the pictures had everyone's out yeah and
I was like when push comes to shove to
actually put it on my myspace opposite
up why because it's like it's one of
them things like that people might laugh
there but also people because obviously
I wasn't I'm like now for example now
yeah so we have a podcast right now yeah
so a lot of people their only
interaction with me yeah is us being
stupid and trashy on here so if I decide
to go on my Instagram and do stupid [ __ ]
people just think that's normal that's
normal
they'll see the funny side whereas like
back then yeah okay I didn't really
obviously I had like bounce between my
boys and stuff like that and I might try
and say something funny and witty here
and there but wasn't outlandish be funny
yeah so for me that was like a
completely as far as they know yeah
that's a completely different change
yeah and they're like what the [ __ ]
so before people loved everything what's
he doing yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is this
guy doing yeah and I was so scared from
a scare because at that time like you
said there was no platform to like show
the kind of comedy person you are oh
[ __ ] that you liked you know I 100 so
yeah if you've done it now you would
have gotten a lot more laughs no and
then if you did it oh yeah that makes
sense
hundred percent and that's the same
fight because I know you yeah that's
funny yeah as you would say two L's
picture in it yeah I regret not doing it
yeah because it could have paid the way
of the person I wanted to be yeah and it
could have opened the door that if I
done it regardless of the responses I
we've got because the real deal is if
people had messaged me and blah blah
what the [ __ ] he doing you idiot I would
have time to [ __ ] off anyway yeah why it
would have shown up people have actually
seen it so yeah okay maybe it's a thing
this is the Tim James trying to do so
like I should have known him and I
probably would've carried on from there
and then I probably would have moved to
YouTube or design it and it were all
this stuff that I've been thinking about
for years and years and years I never
had the balls to do it I would have paid
it from early from time when I said I
was shocked I was [ __ ] my special
time ago myspace was a secondary school
so yeah it would have been like year
nine ten was the Donny called Tom yeah
yeah your first friend are always a
Carmen Carmen back I feel like he was
your first ring because I remember when
I say
I didn't who the [ __ ] tom was and I was
like who's Tom just sitting here with my
friends but we creating it though I
stole so many people's ideas oh yeah
create your own page yeah yeah fam I
used to go on I used to get everyone's
MySpace and looking at look at look at
it and then I would steal ideas
I feel like me I wonder if it's still
you think it's already I don't know I'm
gonna check I don't know why I called
you though I think myspace is locked
entirely do you think I don't know I
think Bebo I never went to beaver but I
did I might rather hide no I don't think
you know is it not MySpace let's go
MySpace Wow
myspace is still about it's still about
I remember my use my email address
because it was my old email yeah I
remember I don't know what my password
it be I will no he's not telling me
their Terms of Service have changed like
I give a like I give a [ __ ]
hang on write say if this you know you
know what's dread well you know how my
say we saw fallin off you know how I
know myspace I've fallen off obviously
they have yeah they've dropped not drop
the ball but they have no pride yeah
they give you the option to sign in with
Facebook or Twitter oh okay they're not
even a compare and yeah you can sign in
with Facebook to MySpace that's
embarrassing that's embarrassing
I would never if I was Tom I'll never
have that if I was Tom right now I can't
sign him
it's not part of top 5 anymore lie in
terms of yeah he's name's actually Tom
yeah for it was invalid email or
password my password even bin I'm not
gonna go through this whole thing
it doesn't nothing to say is the
activated active yeah I'm on their
Wikipedia founded in 2003 16 years ago
and it's mad
yeah my spice was the one boy I used to
make sure my playlist was tight bro all
the newest tracks all the new tracks
damn boy I remember what was it one
t-pain track dropped I think it might be
in church what did you search what did
you and I'm I thought I was the first
man
it's not straight these are all the
first things oh my days are such a
[ __ ] loser bro myspace was so heavy
though man it was sick it was so I was
on it all the time I had in my space
before Facebook I want to say I did I
definitely did I would I got on Facebook
late did I
I think so yeah I think I'm Mike on
Facebook I got late I had MSN around
that time as well I love them as a bro I
love them as Emerson was the was the
money loved Emerson bro I remember I
used to go to my because I my mom was
obviously everyone was a [ __ ] so at my
mom's obviously I lived there a week I
don't think I was allowed in Emerson I
wasn't allowed to like my mom had this
this feeling that no matter what you
download if you have to download it
there's a virus see what everything was
a virus Sophia we weren't allowed [ __ ]
you can sit on it you ain't having it so
MSN wouldn't have to have ever said my
mom's so I used to roll to my dad's on
the weekend Friday and I'm dad pick us
up
pop into my dad's sit down on the
computer connect to the dialog loaded
connect that you said come on right and
there's this you know it's a funny thing
yeah I had so much sauce on MSN yeah and
[ __ ] would empathic everyone did three
one bro I would chat to you for hours on
MSN 20 notice out I was brother was
wanting wanting in my school right cool
Jessica Jessica her name was Jessica
Townsville was her name yeah
from from early Chambord II yeah boardy
ready from body from us early probed bro
Road from young you know I was actually
druid on a tangent the homies sexually
harassed the [ __ ] out
it's red oh and in school you realize
right this is how I know I wish me to
was around when I was in school yeah
yeah II wish it was yeah because I
remember as soon as any girl hit puberty
yeah and there are starts blowing out
and the tea start blowing out the
confident rapey guys will just start
groping ya groping and I'm like brah are
you sure are you sure bro
and then these men were brought to me
like yeah my just nobody sure these are
no one's asking her I was just talking
to her biggest role hand over the
shoulder oh no one's asking no was
asking Jess is it okay I would ask them
does she mind they would tell me you
don't mind I'm rolling over like and I
never had this is how stupid I was I
didn't have the [ __ ] balls to give it
a squeeze yeah cuz I sexual yeah yeah
smack his mouth and dip it yeah nothing
running I will run smack or as I run
party and I'm not James is just a
prankster yeah James is just a silly
little prankster these times I'm just
trying to squeeze I yeah I'm trying to
touch side in a way it feels like bro
I'm trying to feel of my own oh I'm just
trying to figure this out yeah
I want to squeeze I want to touch so ya
know what asking Jessica she used to get
squeezed up constant lays constantly to
the point where she's uncomfortable to
watch and shed body from early brother
that's long for girls no it was [ __ ] so
she used to get squeezed out with a few
other girls and then literally every
[ __ ] Friday but bear in mind I
couldn't say [ __ ] to her in person I
couldn't say [ __ ] to a person every
Friday gets dad's dial-up thinking I'm
thinking
log in to Emerson I'm straight on there
with my tax on time Superman and I'm
like yo Jess
are you saying yeah and we'd chat for
hours for hours and hours and hours and
you say you know I was a dog right
dog I had no interest of anything she
had to say yeah I was just trying to buy
her yeah I haven't banged any while
Isley but in my head I'm like she's
gonna be down wasn't gonna be done and
we're gonna [ __ ] so we're going chat and
chat and chat and she always always used
to shared like a ten year old sister
assign her sister would always pop out
because we used to do accounting okay as
this would always pop up always on the
keyboard I'm gonna go tour get a drink
or half I did like that's my sister for
a bit [ __ ] sister because I waited I
was entertaining and I was there time to
the sister played solitaire whatever I
had on my computer and in a way for it
to come back and we're talking smack
smack smack smack smack Monday would
roll around mute I couldn't look her in
the eye I look on the floor as alabaster
bro embarrassing oh my funny speaking of
dial-up do you remember trying to watch
porn on dialogue like back a day I don't
think I was watching porn on dial-up
days I was I was it was a scary
encounter swear down because obviously
it takes nowadays you've got Wi-Fi got
broadband all of that it's like rap back
then because obviously we've dial-up you
[ __ ] up you can't make calls while
you're on internet yeah I remember I
completely forgot about that yeah I
can't make [ __ ] like Millennials
nowadays have no idea how good they have
it you couldn't make the call
landline cause when you had dial-up oh
it's crazy that's mind-blowing to me bro
anyway I remember this one silo which is
gone it was pink walled have you ever
heard a pink world you know it's
probably still about now
yeah pink world but the thing with pink
quad it was just pictures I didn't know
I don't think back then there was like
porn harp and all that [ __ ] there yeah
it was all animated like anime all
stills hmm everything was still so
that's what I was looking at back in the
day before I went on to like on the sky
like channel 9 9 whatever was red-hot
girl show ever since the dawn still was
on the on the pink ward and Brahman
rough and I remember I think there was a
time where I was on it after school bear
in mind this is like three o'clock three
45 or black or daylight I'm the way my
livery was up is that the computer
in a corner and that Tebow's next to
enemies had never him there I was kind
of tucked away and it was behind the
door as well yeah so I'm I'm doing my
thing I'm dialing up I'm logging in well
enough I'm logging in
obviously I type in P yeah yeah pops
tray up row that autofill is long scared
the living Christ out of me James
scared then living back then I didn't
know anything about incognito I didn't
know anything about do you know you
don't you don't think about the wrongs
there are you in the moment you're in
the moment go and I'm thinking of how do
I don't see back then as well like you
like your mom said anything you download
automatic virus or you assumed yeah yeah
there was a bag of viruses back then
obviously in the bag was a bad idea
viruses back then so anytime pop-ups
anything pop noise you just hit moaning
you say moaning I remember I used to
fear me bro
just no obviously there was no laptops
back then it was shiny all speakers and
everything speakers I don't see was a
boxed in that compete was a box tick
yeah and it was slow so if you're
pressing X it's not exit yeah it's
frozen be you and hold the thing to shut
down the halting such fear ah just to
get hard on such fear such are you here
the fans of time bro oh that's five days
I remember one time yeah because I'm my
dad's my dad used to hook us the [ __ ] up
I had a PC in my bedroom my brother had
a PC in his bed Wow
we had the works on my dad and it was
connected to my TV so my obviously my
mana was fat at a massive TV month we
were live in LA I live in lavish attacks
and then my whole thing was up
yeah I saw porn in there for days yeah
and then one time same thing didn't know
about on incognito privacy mode whatever
went in there and my
whole pieces acting slow as [ __ ] and I'm
like dad can you come sort out my pcs at
mad slow I think my have a virus
sighting is that I have you been
downloaded [ __ ] and I downloaded nothing
I can fix it is a cool I didn't think to
clear my browsing history so my mom's
first thing he's doing check in there
he's checking cookies and all for
caching good famiiy second cache and
cookies my man open the ting and all it
is is like porn this is and it gives
titles fun I know my button interracial
this ebony that bbw this milf that
mature that foul and the way my broom is
outside my bed was here yeah in front of
me was obviously the floor space and
then the thing was here so my dad sat
right from the computer was that behind
my dad so he knows he's watching it I
can see him watching it he knows I can
see all and his silent the whole into
silent and my knees are shaking my knees
are shaking my heart was beard I didn't
know what was gonna happen I didn't know
what the [ __ ] was gonna happen it should
bear porn all it was was born oh my days
and I was just there and I didn't know
first to speak first I'm glad that I
don't know what that is oh just what
kept my mouth shut
my dad's always my dad held it like a
cheat yeah when he called me bashing one
up he held it like a G didn't say [ __ ]
clean the whole thing are rate and just
bounce I rate that highly cuz I must
gotta do what man's gotta do what a
man's got a [ __ ] dude rate that and
bro I was so I will forever raped my dad
for that because that would have ruin my
life
Oh rats every room I've never felt fear
like that in my existence I think I've
said the story about when my dad caught
me watching porn yeah I said it on here
every night yeah I've got beat like like
I've never been beat before in a garden
I will never forget what's your point
from that's embarrassing enough as it is
I'm like pain stars my parents don't
give a [ __ ] I got slapped up in a shop
I'd like parents don't give a [ __ ]
Oh did it anyway discovery is
embarrassment in knowledge and not ya
know a nobody to beat me for I'm already
embarrassed humiliated oh my parents
didn't give a [ __ ] Oh fan madness to me
Jesus Christ is so embarrassing it's so
embarrassing
getting caught is it's not cool
it's not it's not and gay guys like I've
said it my main source for women is
sexual sex whenever guys from there
hunched over and your toes spread my
fingers well like when you're in it and
you can sing good singles bro you're
arched over you would like you're
pushing your heels into the floor to get
a good signature and your toes are
spreading like that's not hot you cut
and you're just there phone and just go
in just fap in fact in [ __ ] fat then
you know go sex there it's just a subtle
you know legs are spread BAM bang bang
so if you walk in say like see if you
would in your girlfriend or your pond or
wherever and she's just going you're
gonna block Oh what did everyone what
you want me to would you want me to I'm
trying to get parties so if a girl would
sit on me
just I'm alright I'm embarrassed I'm
mortified
tell me now whether you want to lock it
off because because we're not gonna have
a normal compac tip just don't look me
in the eye I spoke it to bear like
partners got my girl like girlfriend or
whatever and they've been all the topics
come up and they're like are now to want
to join in like I'm one again you
wouldn't you wouldn't you're such a liar
oh you've never caught anyone you don't
know it looks like you don't recite to
be us it's hideous and it's just a task
well I wouldn't even want them to join
in oh never because guys don't bash for
pleasure it's just yeah it's more of a
necessity than pleasure yeah because
like I'm wanking so I cannot I'm not I'm
not working because I enjoy wanking yeah
like true I actually don't enjoy wanking
I've just beeped it now thank you for
saying that
I enjoyed the 90s city oh I wanted to if
I can get it done in four seconds I
won't get I know force bro it's mad I
don't want it to last at all cause they
is to build up its it all emotion it's
like Oh bro and then yeah and then they
get there not bro for me I want it done
done done done done it's one a nine Kip
I'd do it so I can sleep same that's how
you know when I was a teenager this is
funny because when I was a teenager
before I'd ever had sex like I was in it
for all of it yeah when I was a teenager
I was in it for all
yeah I used to try this edge in ting
everything you do ever do the edging
ting edge it so edging is where you bash
yeah to the point where you're just
about to not completely stop yeah way to
everything simmers down yeah start again
bash tonight and I'm cent zero no it's
torture but when you've never felt [ __ ]
you've never had anything this is all
you've got yeah you don't want to waste
up it's amazing it was amazing I've
never done that my life for all life I
would never in a million years do it now
but back then I was grass him to
anything anything that will get me off
I'm here that funny well it was it was
essential he was [ __ ] essential fair
enough oh [ __ ] you know that's funny
that is hilarious boy Jesus I love those
Pont aux cuz my childhood was just full
of it that's all that's all I did when I
was a kid go to school and watch porn
that's Richie that's literally it
i watch porn for days when I was a kid
days bro same say Oh horny when I was
fat [ __ ] bro we've been through this but
we all know random this is stupid and
random and not funny or anything
why the [ __ ] are Australian chicks so
piff I've been saying this for years
there's something in their water there's
something in their water there has to be
their piff they will always got son
they've got clear ass water they all
they all like they're an advocate
fitness and the only healthy the skin is
always amazing and just banging bro
every single one of them I come across
an Instagram is bang in there all
banging banging everyone in Australia is
banging they must be new provide facts
new provide it's mad to me actually have
I I'm pretty sure the ones that I have
now live in England a hundred percent
100% I'm talking about yeah Soph
Instagram yeah every every yeah that now
lives in England that's Australian is
buzz because they left they left like
anyone they can't get any [ __ ] he's
mad 100%
The Australian's up if is this that's
why I've said to you I want to go to
Australia
we will I want to go to share up within
my lifetime I I'm scared of the animals
they have caught next Tings bro do you
remember there wasn't like a there was a
phase where there was like giant
upside-down bats like giant giant
upside-down bats no room I don't know I
say upside down as cause bats they're
all outside I don't know why I said that
but they were massive they were massive
I know will understand the fear that
will get into me to see a massive
[ __ ] but if I looked up bat a huge
[ __ ] bat I'll smash this camera all
smushed just like anything to get
anything together I'll do whatever it
takes to go oh I will sacrifice anyone
anyone Brooke and it doesn't have to
move it could be asleep I will trash
this entire room I'm getting the [ __ ]
out I'm getting the [ __ ] out of it bro
Australia's a neck like Australia it
doesn't make sense it doesn't if we're
if we're truly living in if we're truly
living in like a simulation of
Australia's hell is hell has to be
Australia is real-life hell yeah from
the animals in Australia Michael I heard
a story one time I was telling mark
that's funny
this guy used to work we've was telling
me a story was blows in the army
yeah he was stationed in Australia for a
little while yeah and they were sleeping
on the floor whatever man
said there's a spider or something I
think it's a spider that injects his
venom and completely numbs you right Oh
completely numbs you your whole body or
just way where it's been where it's been
your around there yeah um so completely
numb to you man said he woke up and
there was a spider eating his face and
half his face was gone I don't know what
spider it was he says [ __ ] massive
and he woke up and half his face was
gone what you mean obviously eat all
night he the thing will be eating his
face all night half his face was gone it
just born a muscle and he couldn't feel
a thing
what the [ __ ] bro this animals in
Australia and with snakes galore know
the snakes below there's crocodiles in
there as well as [ __ ] Kaufer stories
about his crocodiles
it's crocodiles will [ __ ] you there's a
place in Australia can't remember what's
good there's a guy on YouTube called em
[Music]
[ __ ] a comment what his name is but he
does he's got one massive YouTube
channel and he literally goes in search
of like giant wasps and moths and
hornets and [ __ ] the stings you in [ __ ]
that bites you and all that you just
search him for it just for the laugh I
guess yeah and he said there's a place
where like saw where water crocodiles
live you can't go there you literally
can't go there like anything that goes
in that water they're having it mmm
like it's not like where's like our
sharks won't harm you you don't like a
seal and a fan big man if you go in this
water yeah you're not coming out it's
mad and like people like in boats in
rafts or anything from the crocodiles
are having you and there's no two ways
about my day there's no two ways about
it I'm not going there there's a thing I
want to go there so badly over I'll have
to go to a see yeah that's all see I'm
not going to draw rabbits bro these if
anyone's asking me like ah you should go
because you need to do this tour of the
not doing it I'm not doing anything I'm
not doing it there's animals there I'm
not doing any I don't even want to see
what was it like I don't know if they're
like photoshopped or whatever
when they have like like a black thing
on the wall I always see these things on
Instagram but it's like a black mass on
the wall or whatever and some like truck
a pen up there or something and spiders
and they just separate in dip I've seen
that that would solidify that I'm never
leaving my house again like I would I
don't even understand how I would feel
bro
that would scare that will scare me more
than the bad thing oh yeah because there
are hundreds of smoke coming they're
just everywhere
nah bro now scare me next thing so do I
in hey I'm gonna push your when it comes
I can handle them I can't handle them
because I'm I'm not a Ratna phobic like
I'm not scared of spiders I just [ __ ]
hate them
yeah yeah that's the thing I know what
you mean ah is so weird I'm scared of
animals birds obviously Birds we all
know about birds but um sweets mean bro
they give me such high anxiety I know
like I'm are muscles a tense and my neck
is tight I know and I will sacrifice
anyone we already know there's this guy
knows wave you if you man ever with me
if we ever become friends via whatever
reason and we're walking for a street
and a bird comes towards us I will throw
you in front of me I'll grab you I don't
even know my hands doing it I just
grabbed this I just grab and push Romi
Birds we can't handle it I can't [ __ ]
handle it in a victor many times it is
sweetie I'm so angry at the same time
bro I was when I was a kid we my mom
took us to this like country part what
do they call it like like a center box
thing no Center Parcs like he says like
a national park kind of finger was just
like oh it's just a [ __ ] Park yeah
lakes and [ __ ] yeah yeah so we went
there and there was Swans and [ __ ] and
geese so we were feeding the swans bread
I was there I must have been 11 12 I was
there with my cousin yeah
my brother will just feed in swans and
[ __ ] and then one Swan came out of the
water and just out walking towards and
he wants more food and I'm backing up a
little bit I'm still glad she had fear
of things then I didn't know I did I
didn't know I did by clearly dead
because my mom was walking closer closer
closer fam I had one piece of bread left
I threw it he ate it my cousin had more
bread I looked at me wanted more and it
hissed it was attraction and like coming
towards from you know what I have never
felt fear like yeah I grabbed man I
grabbed and I pushed him like a grab
with all my might he was just a meat
shield for me fell grabbling of
everything I had it just [ __ ] pushed
him just take him up
I've never felt anything like it came up
me with chest it stood up straight
it's just rated as a wouldn't warning
quick for bread I was so [ __ ] scared
I was so [ __ ] scared fam terrified of
birds animals are [ __ ] like they're
salesmen bro
animals are something else they are it's
[ __ ] terrifying handle them that's
funny I can't [ __ ] handle them i
disgusting it's [ __ ] disgusting and
insects are a joke I hate them so much
moths spam moths ah why I must surround
when most of flame you know we must have
fly it and you can hear that good
bumping into [ __ ] clearly [ __ ] ISM
they terrify me you know what terrifies
me the most a sort of a video on Twitter
of a sloth just on road it was obviously
sloths are slow yeah they're known for
being slow it's fun and it was slow yeah
because of house carries sloths look
yeah never seen please just google a
sloth or watch a video face and their
plot everything about it because they're
they're huge
yeah they're massive huge so I think
that the the caption was imagine
obviously these [ __ ] are slow yeah
imagine these [ __ ] running that
no no no running no no Rose laughs nah
cuz their nails are longer as well nah
just I'm gone I'm gone but I'll be so
scared even please just Google sloths
just Google us a video of us a lot
oh I was imagining running at you oh I
was listening to a podcast of the day
but then we were like talk about hunting
and stuff like that yeah I talk about
bears
yeah found bears have senses mmm bears
can smell is something ridiculous like
if there's like a rotting deer corpse
like it's like a mile or two away they
can smell it and they can track it down
and they know where it is from a mile
away
madness how long a mile is fam from a
dead corpse and they'll go and back it
firm they were talking about times where
they just roll in it was actually no I
tell you what it was the YouTube guy
again you'd you go again he was in some
woods
this guy I'll I'll find him I watched a
video we got himself in 10 she stung by
this giant Hornet in Japan the Hornet
was [ __ ] huge valid it was huge
but yeah anyway so they were rolling
around in this woods and they saw like a
female bear with her cubs and the
peroneus just came over there if you if
if a bear clocks you in the woods
and is with his Cubs a mother bear
you're done a man said he looked up saw
the mum stopped his boys saw the Cubs
and I was like oh I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die and they didn't have guns or
anything there's not gonna die I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die and then like it
clocked them then stood up on two legs
and man said it's either going to walk
off and ignore us where it's gonna go
run as a 40 miles an hour and kill us
man said he was scared scared I'll put
you there cuz I was just listening I
pictured it and I my heart racing you
imagine a bear I don't even want to bear
to poke me through glass or anything I
know what a bad son acknowledged that
I'm here yeah so man in home terrain and
man stood up looked at me stood up on
two legs like wasy
firm Oh panic bears are on beef they're
on site beef bro bears are on site they
don't care I don't care who you are if
you're walking through they don't care
if you've got them my mistake if you're
in their terrain territories they're
killing me firm I'm so scared
just listen to our drinking how's this
man carrying on his job off yeah like
now the bear gave him a pass he should
have been like guys thank you for that
but it's fine yeah let's just pack up
our [ __ ] and go we're not this isn't for
us the bear could have had us [ __ ] fam
bears and sharks and crocodiles or
tempting scare me
remain at video is that me of that lion
that zoo that guy got trapped in and got
up yeah the Tigers Tigers that's the one
yes I could ate him alive and the one I
put in the group that's what I'm talking
about
oldie one the same one is the same one
you listen to me nice and you two
different ones the one I sent to you was
the guy getting [ __ ] move to buy bear
tiger
the one I put in the group was the old
man walking into the tiger fit into the
lion cage walking back out and as he's
gone to open the door to get out the
lion comes up behind him grabs the back
of his neck and his head and drapes his
him across the floor into the into the
woods and the people are over this side
of the gate I'm screaming I thought was
the same one at an open open open up
there screaming and my sake help me as I
help me help a full man lion has got him
he just drags him drugs him into the
forest oh my god bro this is why you
will never see a black like zookeeper
any any ah dem tings they're black
what's the word I'm looking for the guys
that actually actively go out and look
for animals like a nature and they
certainly know whatever wrong no no oh I
love life and I fear death so much same
they're so synonymous to me I love life
and I feared your field day for your
favorite is the funniest [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard [ __ ] there are certain
things I would never do my life bro the
day we landed I be four so we we were in
a coach and I be for one time go on our
way to hotel and around and it stops in
some random alley somewhere in it the
coach do you remember yes yes some rally
where are we yeah it was some sketchy
area and then I must have turned to you
and said what would you do if like man
in masks just rocked up on the thing
with guns and masks
what's up on the coats right you said
your first response in like four seconds
it was like our Terrans trained do what
you want to me just talk you do what you
want to me just don't kill me you have
no idea how funny that is your fear of
death is beyond bro-bro smile of life I
don't know what they want man said take
my body is yours father do what you need
to do just whatever just
well on that is not obvious I know I
know I know but on the flip side
I'm sorry carry over it's fine
on the flip side the guys that don't fit
there for the guys that about doing all
this extreme activity they do it gives
us knowledge about yeah you know them
there's so much we wouldn't know about
the I wouldn't ya think someone needs to
know that someone needs to reinforce my
fear yeah and to know that I'm
definitely not doing it I'm definitely
not doing that you see when the men when
they take videos where they're like
hanging on a Ledge yes for [ __ ]
building yes or something like that on
their fingers while and you're going
one-handed for a second why would you
want to die if you want to die just kill
yourself kill yourself cuz this is
stupid what how can you life be so numb
that you need that level of adrenaline
to hang on your fingertips on the edge
of a building and the thing is as well
as once you slip you think why did I
even why's that
I fall in 70 stories
you must be fit why did I even do that
for what likes for double taps and
shares likes and shares and retweets
oh these men don't even know my name
they just know I'm a dick here that was
hanging off the side of a [ __ ]
building or off I could never I honestly
could never Oh funny
rappy rappy yes that was fun